yeah good good question and the answer
is were not particularly but we should
and actually we just I just kind of
begun to do this with some of the
evangelical groups here in the US which
is say we've got to have a conversation
about this because if you um if you end
up believing and this is the issue this
is the issue of course to do with the
settlers this is what is so absolutely
vital to realize the problem the problem
is that that of course there have been
there were Palestinians in places here
that have now refugees but also though
the word user and the West Bank and
their view is you know Moses roughly run
about here on meebo looks across the
promised land and declares what it is
now what we've got to do is to say
promised land doesn't mean that that's
you know there is no theological basis
for saying that this is then your state
that this is then you know the the
territory that you have a right to to
control as against the Palestinians but
it's we do have to engage with this
because if we can't actually it is a
continual problem because people simply
believe look that there is you are
asking me to do something and accepting
this two-state solution that's contrary
to my religious bleep and so it's really
important we engage with it and just a
footnote that there is a quite a bit of
literature actually on both non
evangelical an evangelical stripe on the
very issue of the of the land so it's
not maybe in political processes hasn't
flown but it has been definitely
disaster it's not linked back to the
politics which is the problem absolutely
right